يضغطوا عدد من المسؤولين العسكريين بهدوء
على البنتاجون للموافقه على ارسال طائرات
اف 16 الى اوكرانيا حسب ما نقلت صحيفه
بوليتكو عن مصادر مطلعه على المناقشات
الجاريه في هذا الخصوص مشاهدين قال مسؤول
كبير في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه للصحيفه
ان واشنطن لا تعارض الامر غير انه لم يؤكد
صدور اي قرار نهائي حول الموضوع وشدد على
ان اوكرانيا لم تعلم بعد ان هذه الطائرات
المقاتله تمثل الاولويه القصوى مشيرا الى
ان تنتجون يركز طبعا على ارسال القدرات
التي تحتاجها كاف في المعارك الجاريه
كانظمه الدفاع والمدفعيه اذا فالحصول على
مقاتلات اف 16 لم يعد حلما مستحيلا
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا التي تتامل ان تكون هذه
المقاتلات الامريكيه هي الخطوه التاليه من
الدعم الغربي بعد خطوه الدبابات وهذا
الاحتمال ليس مستبعدا ومن الممكن ان يحصل
بالفعل وترسلها واشنطن لعده اسباب ابرز
هذه الاسباب ان اكياف تعول على مسانده
كبيره من الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه اضافه
طبعا لدعم مسؤولين جمهوريين لهذا الموضوع
اضافه الى الاستشهاد بالتحولات الاخيره
لمستوى المساعدات الامريكيه للجيش
الاوكراني فمع بدايه الهجوم الروسي كان
ارسال الاسلحه المضاده للدبابات والطائرات
قد جابلن والسنجر مستحيله لكن كيف حصلت
عليها بعد ذلك ثم اتت المعارضه الداخليه
حول ارسال انظمه الجويه ومع استمرار الضغط
الاوكراني والغربي ودعم عدد من المسؤولين
حصلت ايضا كاف على هذه الانظمه الجويه
كذلك الامر بالنسبه طبعا للدبابات من طراز
ولا يوبار التي كانت شبه مستحيله سيما مع
المعارضه الشديده داخل الولايات المتحده
لكن ما بعد الضغط الا الانفراج واخيرا
الغرب وافقه والهاله عروض الدبابات على
كاف وهو ما قد يتغير بالنسبه لمقاتلات اف
[موسيقى]